hey I want to tell you if the great wits
of the past were living today
and by great wits of the past I mean the
likes of Voltaire Alexander Pope
Oscar Wilde Dorothy Parker Alexander
Woollcott HL Mencken satchel page Yogi
Berra if those brilliant minds were in
this room it would be because they had
been making films and those films would
be films like the jerk that men don't
wear plaid in three amigos if you say no
I'm sorry Tom but I have to disagree I
don't think so I would say back to you
in the parlance of this esteemed honoree
Oh yesterday whoo they would because
Steve Martin is the equal of all those
stellar minds all those timeless wits
Steve Martin has altered the state of
comedy for the last four decades and
imprinted humor for all of time by his
stand-up vice television appearances his
books his memoirs his essays and his
plays he has his output has equaled even
surpassed that of those other classic
wits and in a career of writing films
such as those just mentioned and of
course acting in some we have seen here
tonight pennies from heaven all of you
Roxanne Parenthood steve long ago
established himself as a moviemaking
presence of the first order now named
the geniuses from any other era of
Hollywood Harold Lloyd and Buster Keaton
Preston Sturges and WC Fields Blake
Edwards Woody Allen picked the decade
with the artists who crafted the great
comedy films and performances as well as
a surprisingly astute
maduk stories and recognize the place
Steve Martin has earned in the firmament
he has made films both of his time and
of timelessness now have you heard the
joke about the professional banjo player
who became a millionaire he had been a
billionaire
but then he took up playing the banjo
professionally Steve Martin is both that
very man and his allegorical opposite he
is currently playing the banjo all over
the world and reaping the benefits of
that career choice there's another great
banjo joke here's something you will
never hear in your lifetime
oh that's the banjo players Tesla
Steve Martin is also the kid who did
magic tricks in Disneyland who said
funny things in smoke-filled clubs over
two shows a night who sold out arenas to
thousands of screaming fans and whose
appearances on TV caused the same
sensation the same anticipation as those
of the Beatles and who also went on to
make classic movies that will be seen
and studied and enjoyed and laughed at
forever ladies and gentlemen it is my
pleasure to present this Academy or
honor your honorary award and
recognition of his extraordinary talents
and for the unique inspiration he is
brought to the art of motion pictures to
mr. Steve Martin